KIMBERLY GUILFOYLE, JESSE WATERS
AND GREG GUTFELD.
IT'S 5 CLOCK IN NEW YORK CITY
THE FULL GOP MEMO IS OUT.
CATHERINE WILL BREAK IT DOWN.
>> THIS MAKES THE CASE THAT THE
SECRET NATIONAL SECURITY COURT
WAS KEPT IN THE DARK BY THE FBI
AND JUSTICE DEPARTMENT WHEN THEY
SOUGHT A SURVEILLANCE WARRANT
FOR TRUMP CAMPAIGN AIDE CARTER
PAGE.
THEY WERE NEVER TOLD THE
DEMOCRATS PUT TOGETHER THE
DOSSIER CHRISTOPHER WRAY.
-- CHRISTOPHER STEELE.
HE ADMITTED THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT OFFICIAL WAS
DESPERATE THAT DONALD TRUMP NOT
GET ELECTED.
OHR WAS DEMOTED OVER HIS
CONTACTS WITH STEELE.
FUSION GPS DIRECTED THE TRUMP
PROJECT.
BANK RECORD OBTAINED SHOW HE
WORKED FOR FUSION GPS AND BEGAN
INVESTIGATING TRUMP AS EARLY AS
2016.
REPUBLICAN INVESTIGATORS SAID
THE COURT WAS NEVER TOLD ABOUT
THE DOSSIER'S POLITICAL ROOTS.
QUOTE:
SURVEILLANCE WARRANT HAD IT NOT
BEEN FOR THE DOSSIER.
SAID THEY ENCOURAGED THE
DEMOCRATS TO RELEASE THEIR
VERSION OF THE MEMO.
DO YOU HAVE ANY IDEA WHAT THE
TERMS OF CLASSIFICATION.
ONE OF THE DISTINCTIONS WITH THE
REPUBLICAN STAFF MEMO IT WAS
DELIBERATELY DRAFTED THAT IT
COULD BE MADE PUBLIC QUICKLY.
THE DEMOCRAT'S VERSION IS 10
PAGES LONG AND WOULD BE SUBJECT
TO AN INTER-AGENCY REVIEW.
IT COULD TAKE SOME DAYS.
>> THANK YOU.
>> PRESIDENT TRUMP SHARED HIS
THOUGHT ON THE MEMO FROM THE
OVAL OFFICE MOMENTS BEFORE IT
WAS RELEASED.
>> I THINK IT'S TERRIBLE.
IF YOU WANT TO KNOW THE TRUTH, I
THINK IT'S A DISGRACE.
WHAT IS GOING ON IN THIS
COUNTRY, I THINK IT'S A
ASHAMED OF THEMSELVES AND MUCH
WORSE THAN THAT.
LET'S SEE WHAT HAPPENS.
A LOT OF PEOPLE SHOULD BE
ASHAMED.
KIMBERLY, WHO KNOWS ABOUT THE
FBI PROCESS AND GETTING A FISA
WARRANT.
>> A FEW THINGS JUMPED OUT TO ME
RIGHT AWAY THAT ARE THE
EXCLAMATION POINTS.
WHAT WAS INTERESTING IS THEY
EXCLUDED THE POLITICAL ORIGINS
OFFICIALS.
THEY WERE EXCLUDED FROM THE FISA
APPLICATION.
I FEEL THAT IS GLARING.
IT SHOWS THE MOTIVE AND THE
INTENTION AND INTENT TO DECEIVE
AND DUPLICITY ON THEIR PART.
TRANSPARENT ABOUT.
THEY KNEW ABOUT THE POLITICAL
ORIGINS OF IT, THAT SHOULD HAVE
CAST DOUBT ON THE CREDIBILITY.
THEY PURPOSELY WITH HELD THAT
INFORMATION.
THAT'S A SIGNIFICANT FACTOR.
NUMBER 1 ON MY LIST.
>> JUAN, THE MEDIA HELPED PLAYED
INFORMATION ABOUT THE DOSSIER TO
YAHOO NEWS AND THEY WRITE THE
ARTICLE.
THE FBI WHEN APPLYING FOR THE
WARRANT SAID THERE WAS
CORROBORATION BECAUSE IT WAS IN
YAHOO NEWS.
BUT STEELE USED HIS OWN
INFORMATION TO GET IT THERE.
WHAT DO YOU THINK OF THAT?
>> I DON'T THINK MUCH OF IT.
WITH STEELE ONCE THEY SUSPECTED
HE WAS LEAKING INFORMATION.
THIS WHOLE THING IS COMICAL.
THIS IS COMICAL.
I THOUGHT THIS WOULD BE SOMEBODY
HERE TO CAUSE PEOPLE TO TAKE A
SECOND LOOK.
KIMBERLY IS TALKING ABOUT STEELE
HAVING A POLITICAL DISLIKE FOR
PRESIDENT TRUMP.
THAT DOESN'T SPEAK TO THE
INFORMATION IN THE MEMO.
SECONDLY, IT DID NOT EVEN PROMPT
THE INVESTIGATION.
THE INVESTIGATION STARTED BEFORE
WITH THE NEWS THAT THE FBI
UNCOVERED GEORGE PAPADOPOULOS'S
CONNECTION WITH RUSSIAN AGENTS.
>> THAT'S INCLUDED IN THE MEMOS.
THIS IS NOT EVEN PERTINENT.
I DON'T GET IT.
I AM STRUCK BY THE NUMBER OF
REPUBLICANS WHO HAVE SAID
TODAY -- JOHN McCAIN -- HES THAT
NUNES AND THE REPUBLICANS HERE
ARE DOING PUTIN'S WORK.
ONE SAID IT WAS AN ATTACK ON
AMERICAN INSTITUTIONS.
ANOTHER WE HAVE TO GET PAST
THIS.
PRESIDENT TRUMP SAID ASHAMED.
HE SHOULD BE ASHAMED OF USING
NUNES AND THE CONGRESS IN THIS
WAY.
>> JESSE, YOU THINK DIFFERENTLY?
JUAN THINKS IT'S COMICAL.
BUT YOU ARE NOT LAUGHING.
>> I AM LAUGHING AT JUAN'S
SPEECH.
IT'S A KILL SHOT AND JUAN KNOWS
IT.
THE REASON JUAN CAN'T ADMIT IT,
HE WOULD HAVE TO ADMIT HE'S BEEN
WRONG FOR A YEAR.
THEY WERE CAUGHT RED HANDED.
THE LEFT.
IT INVOLVED THE MEDIA AND
HILLARY CLINTON OPERATIVES IN
FOREIGN COUNTRIES AND THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE AND THE
FBI UNDER BARACK OBAMA.
THE PERSON WHOSE WIFE WAS
WORKING THROUGH FUSION GPS WAS
DEMOTED.
YOU SAY THIS DID NOT PROMPT THE
INVESTIGATION?
YOU KNOW WHAT PROMPTED THE
STRZOK, THE TRUMP-HATING FBI
OFFICIAL.
>> WAIT.
STRZOK RESPONDED WHEN
PAPADOPOULOS WAS FOUND TO BE
ON PAPADOPOULOS OVER A
>> WHAT IS INTERESTING IS
SOMEONE SO LIKE YOU IS SO
DESPERATE.
SIGNING OFF ON 3 FISA
APPLICATION WARRANTS AND KNOWS
THE APPLICATION WAS BASED ON A
DOCUMENT THE DOSSIER WAS PAID
FOR BY HILLARY AND UNVERIFIED
AND SALACIOUS.
WHY WOULD WE DO THAT?
>> THERE IS NO INDICATION THIS
WAS THE TOTAL BASIS FOR IT.
>> JUAN --
ARE DISPUTING THAT McCABE SAID
THOSE EXACT WORDS.
MAYBE THERE WILL BE FOR
INFORMATION ON THAT.
>> SINCE THIS WHOLE THING
STARTED.
THIS NERD SUPER BOWL.
>> [LAUGHING].
>> I SAID -- I DON'T HAVE A DOG
IN THIS FIGHT.
WHEN SOMEBODY SAYS THERE IS
NOTHING TO SEE HERE, THAT MEANS
THERE IS SOMETHING TO SEE HERE.
THIS, THIS IS SOMETHING.
WHEN YOU SEE THIS MOSAIC OF
FALFEASANCE AND YOU SEE THE
SERVERS AND THE POLITICAL ROOTS
OF THIS DOSSIER AND WHY THE
POLITICAL ROOTS OF THE DOSSIER
WERE COVERED UP.
WHY WOULD THEY DO THAT?
IT STINKS OF CLINTON.
SHE -- I MEAN THIS IS TO HELP
HER GET ELECTED.
WE SPENT THE LAST YEAR AND A
HALF HEARING ABOUT COLLUSION
BEEN DONALD TRUMP AND THE
RUSSIANS.
THE REAL COLLUSION WAS COMMITTED
BY THE PERTRAITORS OF THAT
NARRATIVE.
YOU LOOK AT THE MEDIA, DEMOCRATS
AND THEIR LIES IN GOVERNMENT
THOSE ARE THE PEOPLE WHO WERE
COLLUDING AND WERE COLLUDING
BEFORE THE ELECTION.
IF YOU THINK THAT'S NOT HUGE,
THEN YOU ARE PROBABLY A HACK.
>> I AM A HACK THEN.
I REMEMBER HEARING PEOPLE IN THE
CONSERVATIVE ECHO CHAMBER SAY
BIGGER THAN WATERGATE.
>> I DIDN'T SAY THAT.
I DIDN'T THINK IT WOULD BE MUCH
OF ANYTHING.
>> THAT'S WHAT IT IS.
>> [OVERLAPPING TALKING].
>> YOU HAVE NOT RAISED ONE THING
THAT WOULD SAY TO THIS AUDIENCE,
BOY, THIS IS --
>> I RAISEED IT RIGHT NOW.
CAMPAIGN.
THEY USED FALSE INFORMATION TO
SPY ON TRUMP.
>> WHAT FALSE INFORMATION?
>> THE DOSSIER.
>> IT'S NOT.
>> McCABE AND COMEY SAID IT WAS
FALSE.
COMEY SAID SALACIOUS AND
UNVERIFIED.
>> [OVERLAPPING TALKING].
>> WHAT DIFFERENCE DOES IT MAKE
WHO PAYS FOR IT?
>> IF THE INFORMATION IS THE --
>> [OVERLAPPING TALKING].
>> IT'S NEVER BEEN VERIFIED.
WITH A LIBRARY CARD.
>> YOU HAVE EVER TRIED THAT?
>> I AM CURIOUS ABOUT THIS.
IF CARTER PAGE IS UNDER A FISA
WARRANT IN 2013.
YOU HAVE TO GO TO THE FISA COURT
EVERY 90 DAYS TO KEEP UP THAT
WARRANT.
2013 AND 2015.
WE DON'T KNOW IF THIS IS A NEW
WARRANT ABOUT CARTER PAGE.
>> THE PROBLEM IS THE CHRONOLOGY
ISSUE HERE.
WHEN DID THEY GET IT?
AT WHAT TIME?
IT GOES TO THE LARGER ISSUE OF
VERACITY IN TERMS OF THE CONTENT
AND THE FACTS THAT ARE ALLEGED
THERE.
IF YOU HAVE A QUESTION ABOUT
THAT, YOU HAVE TO VERIFY IT TO
MAKE SURE THAT IT WAS
SUBSTANTIATED AND THERE WAS
INITIAL PROOF OR EVIDENCE TO
SUPPORT ANY OF THIS.
>> ONE OTHER THING ON THIS LEGAL
POINT.
EPT IF YOU ARE A FISA JUDGE AND
YOU ARE PRESENTED INFORMATION
THAT YOU THINK WAS BASED ON
FAULTY INFORMATION, HOW MAD
WOULD YOU BE?
>> FURIOUS!
BE HELD IN CONTEMPT OF COURT.
LYING TO THE COURT.
FALSE AFFIDAVITS.
THIS GOES TO THE INTEGRITY OF
THE WHOLE JUDICIAL PROCESS.
COURT.
>> IMAGINE IF YOU ARE PRESENTING
TO THE JUDGE.
YOU DON'T SAY ONE.
MY PIECES OF EVIDENCE IS AN
ARTICLE FROM YAHOO NEWS.
THAT'S WHAT THEY ARE SAYING IS
ONE OF THE PIECES.